in this video you will learn how to make
a very basic biochar fertilizer this
fertilizer will work well with soil
conditions and crops common in north
thailand but also in southeast asia in
general you will need a hoe
you're in
em
20 kilograms of rich soil preferably
inoculated with mycorrhizae 20 kilograms
of dried manure that's about two large
rice bags 20 kilograms of biochar that's
roughly three large rice bags choose a
flat hard surface and cover it with
heavy construction plastic empty the
three bags of biochar into the center of
the plastic using a simple watering can
or just a bucket put the urine all over
the biochar lots of it spread the two
bags of dried manure on top of the
biochar pour more
urine
on top of that top the pile with a bag
of soil sprinkle even more urine on top
of that begin to mix your ingredients
together urine you should start to leak
out the bottom when it does mix some
more stop when you think that the pile
will absorb no more urine you want as
much urine your fertilizer is possible
because it has lots of nitrogen
potassium and phosphorus fill your
watering can with em and sprinkle em all
over while you keep mixing you can learn
about em in the two warm heart videos
making em solution and using em cover
the finished biochar fertilizer mix and
trench around it to protect it from rain
after three months you will have a rich
powerful fertilizer in our experiments
this fertilizer performed as well as
your standard npk and it's free it also
restores the natural fertility of your
soil and biochar fertilizer traps
pesticide leftovers so they do not end
up in your fruits and vegetables where
they can poison you and your family
thank you for watching and from all of
us at warmheart may your costs be low
and your yields high
[Music]
you